juste sur le tourisme pour finir
il ya un endroit qui est très
touristique sur le territoire français
c'est la corse et je sais pas s'il ya la
colère sociale qui en corse aujourd'hui
c'est l'argument d'attractivité de la
corse mais dans cette es juste pour
parler ce à quoi tiennent et la révolte
de la population corse et notamment de
la jeunesse corse qui est complètement
légitime à notre avis elle est le
résultat aussi que ça de ses discours
parce que il ya le piège du discours
attractif
attractivité d'un territoire mais déjà
assurons la démocratie pour une
population respectons la population de
dans ces conditions de vie dans ces
revendications y compris démocratique
est de soins du là on en est pour parce
qu'on appelle le droit des peuples à
disposer d'eux mêmes et là pour le coup
c'est des droits des peuples et des
populations a disposé par elle-même la
reconnaissance d'un statut la
reconnaissance d'une langue la
reconnaissance d'une culture le droit à
ces populations à de pratiquer leur
culture au quotidien et de s'organiser
comme elle le souhaite et de ce point de
vue là ça pète en corse parce qu'il ya
eu un déni de démocratie et heureusement
que ça pète à des moments parce que
c'est comme ça que ça peut faire bouger
les choses donc c'était exprimer la
solidarité par rapport au mouvement en
corse
[Musique]